ProPublica says three University of
Mississippi students it's a possible
civil rights investigation by the
Justice Department after a controversial
photo of them became public the image
posted to the private Instagram account
of one of the group shows them in front
of a bullet-ridden sign honoring Civil
Rights icon Emmett Till while illness
declined to take any disciplinary action
when the picture was brought to its
attention in March the local Kappa Alpha
fraternity chapter suspended them after
learning of the photo on Tuesday chills
1955 murder served as a catalyst for the
civil rights movement and obviously this
sign has been in this memorial has been
defaced the fact that they're smiling
the fact that they're taking that
picture in the dead of night it's a
remote location near the Tallahatchie
River extreme disrespect Adam sirwhere
what a great piece for the Atlantic
about cruelty being the point see that
there that it these memorials were
supposed to teach you about history to
pull a bullet hole through it is part of
the definition of ignorant maybe some
people can learn from the history at
this point now and how inappropriate it
absolutely was